I'm 30 feet down using a dining system
I'd never tried before called snuba I'm
trying to keep my air hose from
strangling me praying I don't run into a
great white
below the surface I try to focus on
finding a crayfish I fight through the
thick kelp underneath it
these Krays are hiding somewhere in the
nooks and crannies limbs on the line I
place my hand into the unknown of each
dark hole damn these crazy move by
lightning finally I managed to spot a
Cray poking his head out of a crack in
the rock it fights me with all of its
might using its powerful tail to break
from my grasp
while I've done a little diving in my
life I'd never quite experienced
anything as majestic or rewarding as
catching at a Z cray
[Music]
look at the size of that baby man they
move fast
yeah yeah right I can't wait to taste
the motor right there and the sweetest
thing you'll ever taste guarantee hard
work done it's time for Shane to make
the most of this beauty by cooking it
two ways
while the amazing tale goes into the pot
Shane serves up some crayfish sashimi
look at it gonna throw in it beautiful
sabe nice look at that the sheen on that
is incredible isn't it yeah
bloody you know that this delicious
always tastes a bit better when you've
earned it next
Shane serves it simply steamed the money
this is where it's at
nice look at that baby
oh my lord god the weight of that yeah I
mean it's enough for six there is enough
you've done extremely well today look at
that
Wow that is delicious Joe I'm amazed of
the yields in terms of that's the muscle
there you felt the power of how much it
is and here you can see yeah see how it
all equates that crayfish was
translucent delicious meaty sweet and
super firm incredible I'm definitely use
it for my face at the end of the week
I'd love you to come and join us I would
love to you know what goes really well
with this a bit of wallaby I think you
need a bit of game in there bit of each
I know a lady that might be how to help
you out service yeah don't ask any other
locals for Sara Sara yep
loves a bit of fire yep she'd be right
up your alley the addition of a protein
that wallaby would be amazing yeah
that's because mainly in serpent her
that has to be a centerpiece on my feast
do I do it like a seven turfed I keep it
separate I got to think about that but
what I have got is an amazing start
because that crayfish it's like the
rolls-royce at sea basically travels
they like to catch you at the end
want to see more for my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips